JONATHAN: Good afternoon,
and welcome to Talks
at Google in Cambridge, Mass.
Today, it's my great pleasure
to introduce Bernard Carlson.
Dr. Carlson is here to discuss
his acclaimed biography,
"Tesla-- Inventor of
the Electrical Age."
Tesla certainly needs
no introduction here.
Bernie Carlson might,
but rest assured,
he is also a major dude.
Here are a few highlights
from his extensive CV.
He is the Joseph L. Vaughan
Professor of Humanities
and chair of the Department
of Engineering and Society
at the University of
Virginia, where he also
holds a joint appointment
with the History Department.
As an historian of
technology, Bernie
has written widely on
invention and entrepreneurship
as well as on the
role of technology
in the rise and fall
of civilizations.
His publications
include "Innovation
as a Social Process--
Elihu Thomson and the Rise
of General Electric,
1870 to 1900"
and "Technology in World
History," in seven volumes.
In 2008, the latter was awarded
the Sally Hacker Prize--
great name-- from the Society
for the History of Technology,
as the best book aimed
at a broad audience.
And among many other
accomplishments,
he recently completed
a five-year term
as executive secretary
of the Society
for the History of Technology.
Please join me in
welcoming Bernie Carlson.
[APPLAUSE]
BERNARD CARLSON: Thanks.
Well, thanks for coming out,
and thank you, Jonathan,
for that kind invitation.
It's a great pleasure be
back in Massachusetts.
While I now live in Virginia,
I spent much of my youth
and education up here.
I studied at Holy Cross
College, about 40 miles
away in Worcester.
I did my post-doc at the
Harvard Business School--
yes, that school, the business
school across the river.
And more importantly, just
around the corner from here,
I did my sabbatical in
1994 and lived at Eastgate.
Practically, you can see
it right out the window.
So it's a great
pleasure to be back here
and to talk to you
about Nikola Tesla.
And part of my
purpose today is this,
as I was saying to Jonathan,
is to insert ideas about Tesla
into the conversations,
into the thinking,
into the work that you have to
do every day here at Google.
I am a historian in
technology by criminal trade,
but I spend my life
in engineering schools
and run the largest
non-technical department
in the engineering school
at, as I like to say,
Mr. Jefferson's Vo
Tech and University.
And I am really interested
in that interplay
between technology and
the rest of society.
That's why it's called the
Department of Engineering
and Society.
But I'm really interested in
how we make the next generation
of outstanding innovators.
How do we train people
to do the magic that
is so important for our society
and for the global economy?
So Tesla is an ideal
subject for that
because he's not somebody
who's just a mythic character.
He's an individual who
has, as you'll see today,
important things to tell us
about how technology gets done,
whether we're talking
in the 19th century
or we're talking in
the 21st century.
But let's just talk for a moment
about Tesla in popular culture.
You can summarize where he
sits in popular culture.
He is, indeed, a figure
in popular video games,
like the "Dark Void," but
he has had a whole range
of roles in popular culture.
Some people say he's a genius.
He is the Leonardo of
the 20th century who
invented everything-- everything
that has to do with electricity
and electronics.
There are other people who sort
of say, oh, he's not a genius.
He's really kind of a lunatic.
He's a nutcase.
He had all sorts of
wonderful dreams,
but he never
finished 3/4 of them.
And, in fact, in his dying days
in the late 1930s and 1940s,
he spent most of the time in the
park behind the New York Public
Library feeding pigeons.
Or if you don't like either
of those two explanations,
he's a space alien who, indeed,
came to Earth from Venus
on the wings of a giant
dove to save mankind
from the horrors of
atomic armageddon.
Needless to say, this is a book
that was published in 1951,
and I always trust all books
that are published and printed
in green ink.
And, indeed, the book
where that idea comes from
is titled, "On the
Wings of a Dove,"
published by Margaret
Storm, and the book
is printed in green ink.
I'm not sure how many books
are printed in green ink,
but this one, when I saw
that, I sort of said, ooh,
that's a really
authoritative source.
OK, so that's Tesla in
the popular culture.
My argument for
you today is this.
Tesla is valuable if we're
stand in engineering schools
where I work, or we're
standing in business schools,
or we're operating
in companies today.
Why?
He invented two
disruptive technologies.
One is the
alternating-current motor
that he worked on in the 1880s
which completely revolutionized
how we consume energy in our
lives today all over the world.
If that was not enough, for
a second act, in the 1890s
he worked on wireless
transmission of power.
He had a vision that radio
waves or electromagnetic waves
should be used not just
first for broadcasting
or for communication
purposes, but should
be used to actually
transmit power from point A
to point B. In a
certain sense, and this
is why I let the
publisher title the book,
"Tesla-- Inventor of
the Electrical Age,"
he is one of the few
guys who contributed
to both electric power and
to electronic communications.
So Tesla is an
interesting individual
because he had one great
success and he had one, well,
un-success, shall we say?
So he allows us to
look at what makes
for big, breakthrough
technologies
and what doesn't make for great,
breakthrough technologies.
He has a success and a failure.
And we can do so
through Tesla's career
without resorting to the
standard explanations, which
is we often sort of say, oh,
breakthrough technologies.
Amazing things-- it's genius.
You've got to be Steve Jobs.
Or they say, it's
just dumb bunny luck.
You've got to be Steve Jobs.
OK, and I want to get away
from-- with my students,
with you-- thinking about
breakthrough technologies
as a result of genius or luck.
To underline where I'm
going with this, some of you
are probably familiar
with how economists
look at technological
change over the long haul.
And they often,
based on work done
by a Russian economist
in the 1920s,
talk about Kondratieff
curves, which
is that there's an ebb and flow
over a long period of time,
from the 1700s to
the 21st century.
And there are waves of
technological change.
OK, now, most people,
they look at this
and they say, oh,
well, if it was 1880,
it's time for that wave that's
electricity and chemistry.
If it's 1910, it's time
for the automobile.
And they don't
really stop and think
that the arrival of those
different waves and the shape
of those waves and the
timing of those waves
is so dependent on individuals.
Submitted for your
consideration--
what's behind that
curve is not just
big, structural
changes in the economy
or the availability
of technology,
but individuals who shape
the technology to match up
to the social and cultural
opportunities of the time.
Tesla is one of those guys.
George Westinghouse is another.
Thomas Edison is a third,
and you could, indeed,
argue about the automobile.
It's somebody like Henry
Ford or Alfred P. Sloan.
So I'm after big
fish here in terms
of talking about Tesla
and disruptive innovation.
Now, I spent 15 years
working on Tesla.
And you might sort
of say, oh, my God.
I heard the laugh in
the back of the room.
Oh, he spent 15
years on this guy.
Why?
Because he was an intriguing
character to deal with.
I had to figure out
how to weave together
several different social
roles that are not normally
juxtaposed.
First off, he is an inventor.
He is somebody who worked
in the technological realm
and did successful,
cutting-edge technology.
At the same time, he
functioned a little bit more
like an artist than a scientist.
A lot of people sort of
say, oh, Tesla, inventor
and then scientist.
I'm like, slow down.
Slow down, there, dude.
I'm not sure about
this science thing.
He is definitely like an
artist, and in particular
because he's more intuitive.
If you asked Tesla what-- or
you went to his laboratory
in the 1890s and you watched
him work, what you would see
is you wouldn't see a lot
of tinkering and working
with wires and messing
around with stuff, which
is what you would see if you
want to Edison's laboratory
in the same time period.
Edison was a
tinkering kind of guy.
Tesla, on contrast,
was what you might
call a theoretical inventor.
It all happened up here.
And it all turned much more less
on the hands-on experimentation
than on intuition,
on having an idea
and then imposing it on reality.
In that sense, he's
more like an artist
and less like a scientist.
Now, lots of people
would sort of
say, oh, Tesla-- world's
worst businessman.
Submitted for your
consideration,
one of the things I
want to convince you
in the next few minutes is
this, that Tesla was actually
a pretty smart entrepreneur,
that he had a business
strategy for making money.
We don't appreciate
it, necessarily,
because it doesn't
conform to what
we think are the standard
ways that we believe inventors
in the 19th century operated.
So Tesla kept me busy for 15
years because I had to move,
weave together inventor,
artist, entrepreneur.
Now, to pull those
things together,
I developed a set of themes.
And, indeed, I actually
thought that the book
ought to be called,
"Ideal and Illusion."
And my publisher said,
oh, don't do that,
because everybody
will think it's
some sort of theological tract.
Nobody will buy any
copies, and there you go.
So I said, OK, but at
the heart of the book
are two dueling ideas about
Tesla's style as an inventor.
And I think inventors,
like artists, have a style.
They have a way of doing things.
They have a way of making
sense of the world,
of making meaning.
Tesla's was a tension
between ideal and illusion.
Tesla believed, based on
his religious background--
his father was a priest in
the Serbian Orthodox Church--
that behind everything in
the world, whether it was
made by God, i.e. animals
and plants and minerals,
or made by man, there was a
fundamental principle that
was behind it and that
the job of an inventor
was to find the perfect
way to make an invention.
And if you could
glean, you could
discern that perfect
idea, then you
would have a great invention.
Now, this is very
platonic, as in the sense
of what Plato had to
say in his dialogs,
particularly the
analogy of the cave.
And you may remember
that only the philosopher
king or the philosopher
can actually see the truth.
Everybody else is
trapped down in a cave,
looking at flickering
lights and debating
the nature of those
flickering lights
that they see on the
walls of the cage.
Mere mortals are stuck trying
to deal with approximations
of the true, illusions.
Tesla believed that you had
to develop illusions, stories,
values, metaphors, that
allowed people to begin
to see where the ideal was.
And he was willing to
put a lot of effort
into capturing
people's imagination.
And then one of
the things that's
really important about
him for the young people,
the undergraduate
engineers that I teach,
is to remind them
that it's not just
about getting the code right.
It's about the
story that you tell
about your software that engages
the imagination of people.
So where did Tesla develop
this mix of ideal and illusion?
Tesla was born in 1856
to a Serbian family who
was living in what is
today Croatia but back then
was the Austrian Empire.
It was a section of the
Austrian Empire that
was kind of a military
zone, a buffer
zone between the
Austrian heartland
and the Ottoman
or Turkish Empire.
And the Austrians, to manage
that zone, mixed Muslims
and Christians, i.e.
Catholics, and Serbian Orthodox
people and bundled them
all together so
that nobody really
controlled the entire area.
And sadly, the
history of Yugoslavia
is a result of that mixing
up of all of these people.
And, indeed, where
Tesla was born
is still a very contested,
complicated place.
I've not been to his birthplace,
have no particular desire to go
there.
OK, now, as a child, Tesla
had, as I said in the book,
he had an interesting
childhood, way
more interesting than certainly
I had and I'm not sure
that I want my daughters
to ever have had.
He had a problem
with his imagination
and with nightmares.
So if you said to
Tesla, juicy apple,
he'd see out there in sort
of a three-dimensional space,
he'd see this
beautiful red apple.
And it would be all juicy,
and he'd start salivating.
And he'd say, oh,
apple, apple, apple.
I mean, he's a little
kid, and he could not
get rid of that vision
of that juicy apple.
It would haunt him all through
the day, once you started down
this path with that particular
image, all through the night.
OK, and needless to say,
this was a troubling thing
when you're a little kid.
About 10, 11, 12,
somewhere in that zone,
preadolescence,
he reads a novel.
And the novel basically talks
about an individual who's
kind of a
good-for-nothing prince
but proves himself
to his monarch-- it's
set in the Austrian Empire--
and proves himself to his king
and becomes a hero because
he develops discipline.
He develops willpower.
And young Tesla decided that he
was going to develop willpower.
And the willpower that
he needed to develop
was all around getting
control of these images.
So instead of just being
overwhelmed by the images,
he imposed an order on them.
And he began to go,
in his imagination,
on fabulous journeys.
He developed entire cities.
He developed imaginary friends,
indeed, imaginary societies.
And to go from one place to
another in his imaginary world,
he flew.
Well, along the way, he decides
that there shouldn't only
be flying in his
imaginary world.
There should be flying
in his real world.
So he decided, when
he was about 12 or 13,
to build for himself a flying
machine, which probably
consisted of some sort of
pump or machine on his back,
like a backpack, with
a helicopter up there.
That's about as much as
I know, but it was based
on some vacuum-pump principle.
And he built a prototype.
And lo and behold, the
prototype moved a little bit.
And Tesla was elated
because it confirmed
that what he could
imagine in his mind
could happen out there
in the real world.
And that set him on the
path to being an inventor.
If I can imagine it up here, and
it happens in the real world,
then there's some rationality or
meaning to all of these things
that I can imagine.
It sets Tesla up, however,
in a complicated, tricky way,
because he's always looking for
the upside of his discoveries.
He's always looking, as Karl
Popper the famous philosopher
would say, for
confirmatory evidence.
But more on that
in a little bit.
Tesla goes to
engineering school,
kind of violates
the family norms.
Both his father and
all of his uncles
were priests in the
Serbian Orthodox Church.
He didn't want to
go into the church.
He convinced his father that
he ought go study engineering,
and he studied engineering
in Graz, Austria.
There, in a story
that's interesting
but I'm going to just
kind of pass over,
he decides after watching a
demonstration in his physics
lecture that he should invent
a better electric motor,
a motor that is sparkless.
To develop that idea,
he thinks that it's
going to use a rotating
magnetic field.
I'll explain that in a moment.
To get more
information about how
all sorts of electric motors
and electric machines work,
he worked for several Edison
companies in different cities.
First in Budapest, where helps
install a telephone exchange,
then he goes to Paris, helps
install electric lights.
He does such a
good job that he's
transferred to the New York
offices of the Edison company.
But that really, if you
will, is his graduate school
in electrical engineering.
That's where he really learns
the technical business.
He leaves the
Edison organization.
And after a number
of adventures,
he teams up with a pair of
individuals, Charles Peck
and Alfred Brown, who
allow him to develop
his alternating-current motor.
Now, there are two
physics lessons
in this particular class.
I probably don't need to
apologize for this audience,
but sometimes I
often have to say,
you know, there's going to
be a little science here.
You know, just bear with
the historian teaching
a little bit of science.
In 1887, Tesla perfects an
alternating-current motor.
Now, all motors, whether
they be DC or they be AC,
work on the principle
that there are two pairs
of magnets in the motor.
There's a stationary
pair, called the stator,
and there's a moving
pair, called the rotor.
As long as those
two pairs of motors,
the stator and the rotor,
have different poles,
that is to say a north pole--
or they have the same poles,
excuse me.
The north pole and
a north pole meet,
they push away from each other.
Because if it was a
north to south pole,
they'd be attracted
to each other.
So as long, at any
given moment, as you
have one set of magnets
moving around, that
is to say rotating, those
always have a north pole.
When they meet
another north pole,
then they'll push
away from each other.
So Tesla's big idea, if we look
at this diagram from his 1887
patent, is the
doughnut is the stator.
And it has four coils,
four electromagnets.
And this rectangle that you
see in the middle is the rotor.
So every time this piece
of the rotor gets up there,
it has to have a north pole so
it's repelled by the stator.
Now, before Tesla, everybody who
was in the electrical business
said, the part of
the motor where
you change the magnetic
field is the rotor.
In other words, you change
the magnetic field in this,
and you leave the magnetic
field and the stator stationary.
Tesla said, no, no, no.
I'm going to do this entirely
backwards to everybody else.
I'm going to be a maverick.
We're going to induce a
magnetic field in the rotor,
and we're going
to have a rotating
magnetic field in the stator.
So the rotating magnetic
field goes around and around
in the doughnut.
Why?
Through the magic of alternating
current, which I am not
going to explain to you
here-- if you feed two
alternating currents
into the doughnut,
into those four coils, and if
the two alternating currents
coming off of the
generators, this
is the generator over here,
are 90 degrees out of phase,
you can create a
rotating magnetic field.
In other words, if we
start here at noon,
this is going to be north.
And then the north pole
is going to go here.
The north pole is
going to go here.
And it's going to go
round and round and round,
and it's going to induce an
opposite magnetic and electric
field in the rotor.
Science lesson number
one is now concluded.
OK, this was an amazing thing.
It allowed for Tesla
to patent and develop
the first practical
alternating-current motor,
which allowed electricity
for the first time
not just to be used
for lighting, that's
what Edison
developed, but indeed
be used for all sorts
of power applications--
elevators, fans, machine
tools, moving assembly lines.
When Tesla develops
this configuration
of the motor in 1887.
It essentially looks like this,
but instead of that rectangle
there, what he did to basically
get proof of concept is he
took one of those
shoe polish tins,
the Kiwi shoe polish tins.
Do you all know it?
It's kind of like this.
And he basically, he had
no shoe polish in it.
And he basically
in the middle of it
put a thumb tack so
it was on a pivot.
And he dropped that in the
middle of the doughnut.
And the whole tin
can went, whee.
And Tesla went, eureka.
So he brings in one of his two
backers, [INAUDIBLE] Brown,
who is a little more technically
minded than the lawyer,
Charles Peck.
And he shows to Brown that
the tin can is spinning around
in this coil.
And I have this vision of Brown
kind of peeking into the motor,
looking into the
doughnut, and seeing
this tin can go spinning around
and then looking at Tesla,
going, you brought me over here
to show me a spinning tin can?
Isn't that special.
And Brown, basically, went back
to Peck and said, I don't know.
This guy is not really
getting with the program.
I'm not sure whether
it's worth all the money
we're spending on him.
So Tesla realizes that
he's got to convince,
he's got to come up
with the right illusion
for his technical backers,
for Peck and Brown.
And so he waits a couple
days, and he goes back
to their offices, which
are around the corner.
All of this is taking place
in downtown Manhattan,
in and around where the
World Trade Center was, right
around ground zero.
And he walks into Peck
and Brown's office,
and he says to Peck
and Brown, so, you
know how Christopher Columbus
got the money for the Nina,
the Pinta, and the Santa Maria.
And then Peck and Brown
go, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
They got it from Queen
Isabella, and Queen Isabella
hawked her jewels.
And Tesla says, ah,
but what did Columbus
do to convince Queen Isabella?
And as the legend
goes, Columbus was
in the court of Queen
Isabella and basically
was trying to convince
all of the experts, all
the scholastics that
were around the court,
that, indeed, the
world was round.
And they were arguing
with him, and they
were going back and forth.
And finally, I'm
from New Jersey.
I apologize.
Columbus, who was Genovese,
he probably did this.
He had had it up to here.
And he said to the scholastics,
this is Columbus speaking,
he says, can you make
an egg stand on end?
And the scholastics
went, oh, I don't know.
I don't know.
They're like
promotion and tenure
committees in engineering
schools, but that's an aside.
You know, terribly unfair to
my colleagues, but I apologize.
But they say, oh,
we can't do that.
And Columbus says,
bring me the egg.
And I imagine this
egg comes out,
you know, with a little
flunky on a purple,
you know, like, a
nice little pillow.
And there's the egg.
Columbus says,
bring me the spoon.
And he grabs the
egg, takes the spoon,
whacks off the bottom of
the egg, stands the egg up.
And the scholastics are
like, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
And Queen Isabella
says, I like that guy.
I'm going to give him money.
So Tesla repeats this whole
story to Peck and Brown
and says, if I can make
the egg stand on end
and go one step further
and make the egg spin,
will you give me the money
to patent this thing?
And they say, OK.
So the next day, a
couple days later,
and only in New York, Tesla
runs home and on the way home
finds where he can
buy a copper egg.
OK, it must have been about
the size of an ostrich egg.
And he basically
puts the egg on top,
as you can see in the
picture, of the doughnut coil.
Peck and Brown come
in, and they say, OK.
Tesla turns on the
electric current.
The rotating magnetic field
is created in the doughnut.
And the egg starts
off on its side
and starts spinning and spins
fast enough that it comes up
and winds up spinning around
its vertical axis, like that.
Peck and Brown look at each
other and say, he's our guy.
We're going to spend the money.
We're going to get
this puppy patented.
And as a result, Peck and Brown
put together a set of patents,
and Tesla becomes famous.
Now, Peck and Brown taught
Tesla an important lesson.
They said, look.
The way we're going to make
money is we're going to patent.
We're going to promote.
We're going to sell.
So first we're going to
get the very best patent
lawyer in town, and he's
going to get you outstanding
patents for this design-- a mix
of specific patents and system
patents.
Next, they said, you're going
to do a series of lectures.
You're going to do a
series of newspaper.
We're going to get
everybody excited.
We're going to have
them go, oh, my God.
This is the greatest
thing since sliced bread.
And then when the
hype peaks, we're
going to sell to
the highest bidder.
In this case, it was
George Westinghouse,
and Tesla basically
walked away with the cash.
This is a strategy that's
very different than what
we attribute to most inventors.
Most inventors, like
Edison, we assume
made their money because they
actually integrated forward
and decided that they had to
manufacture their inventions.
If you look at the self-help
literature in the 19th century,
essentially, the
self-help literature says,
manufacturing is for suckers.
What you want to do is
get control of your idea,
sell it to somebody who actually
has the industrial capability
to manufacture your invention.
You don't want to get
into manufacturing
if you can humanly help it.
That's what Tesla did.
So Tesla goes to Westinghouse,
spends about nine months
at Westinghouse, working on the
routine engineering problems,
and basically says,
this isn't for me.
So what do you do?
There's no Disneyland,
so what do you do?
Well, if you're Tesla you go,
in 1889, to the Paris World's
Fair, which is,
indeed, the World's
Fair where the Eiffel
Tower is unveiled.
And there he, depending on how
you want to think about it,
he drinks absinthe or he drinks
coffee with graduate students
in physics and
electrical engineering.
He meets one who studied
with [INAUDIBLE],
got his PhD with
[INAUDIBLE] in Paris, and is
on his way to study with this
guy, Heinrich Hertz in Germany.
And Tesla says to the
graduate student, so what
are you going to work with
when you get to Hertz?
And the student says, I'm
going to work with Hertz
because Hertz has figured
out that there are, indeed,
electromagnetic waves
that are invisible.
James Clerk Maxwell,
in the late 1860s,
does for electricity
and magnetism and light
what Newton did for mechanics.
That is to say, he
developed a series
of laws, a set of
principles, that
organized the whole darn thing.
Maxwell says that if you
look at my equations,
they predict that there
are waves that are not
visible to the human eye.
And everybody says,
well, that's nice.
So where are they?
Hertz, probably the
best experimentalist
of the late 19th century,
student of Helmholtz,
basically says at his laboratory
in the University of Bonn,
he says, right.
Bring on the toughest problem.
And Hertz figures out how
to detect those radio waves,
those electromagnetic waves.
And he does so
using an apparatus
that you see up there.
And most of this apparatus,
all this stuff up here,
is a telegraph key
and a Ruhmkorff coil,
a transformer with two
windings on the same core.
And down here, this thing
that looks like an earring,
is the receiver.
And Hertz walked around his
laboratory with this ring,
and he basically
detected radio waves
because whenever there
was a spark here at h,
there was a spark here
at l in the receiver.
So Tesla finds out
about all of this.
Now, you're a good inventor.
What do you do when you see a
scientific discovery like this?
Well, you want to soup it up.
And that's exactly
what Tesla did,
is the Tesla coil that
we all know and love.
And depending on how I
travel, I often bring,
for demonstrations like
this, a Tesla coil.
But I wasn't sure whether
I'd ever actually get it
in the building.
I probably could have gotten
it in the building here today.
But this is a Tesla
coil down here,
which is essentially a
high-frequency, high-voltage
transformer, all
the parts of which
are tuned to get maximum, high
voltage, high frequency out
of it.
And it's all based on souping
up the Hertz apparatus.
So what do you do with
electromagnetic waves?
Now, notice, I'm calling
it electromagnetic waves
because radio is a
term that only comes
into use about 1903 or 1904.
So if we're talking
before that period,
we've got to talk about them
either as Hertzian waves or E
and M waves.
Tesla says, hey,
I'm a power guy.
I made motors.
I'm going to do something
on the power side.
I'm not really worried about
this communication stuff.
And everybody else
in this time period
that knew about Maxwell's
work and Hertz's work
was also interested
in power applications.
Tesla says, here's
what we're going to do.
If you have a Tesla coil and you
have a Geissler tube near it,
it instantaneously goes off.
It starts lighting up,
all by its little self.
Every time the Tesla
coil discharges,
you get a flash in
the Geissler tube.
And the Geissler tube
is basically filled.
It's a tube that you basically
take all the air out of it.
And then you put a little
bit, a little bit of something
like argon or neon gas inside.
So it's like a neon tube.
So Tesla said, I'm going to
make an entire wireless lighting
system around that.
And here, he's
demonstrating it in New York
at Columbia College in 1891.
He's got two big zinc
plates on either side.
They're connected to a
Tesla coil that's over here.
He's about to take these tubes
that are about, like, this
long, and the lights
are going to go out.
And he's going to step
between those two plates.
The plates are
charged, and he's going
to start waving
these giant tubes.
And they're going to
light up, wirelessly.
In other words, you're
not going to need
any of these annoying wires.
You could have a wireless
lighting system in your home.
And Tesla's vision was that you
would have metallic wallpaper.
And you would basically
have your lights on stands.
And you would just
rotate the light
so it was aligned with
the electromagnetic field
of the two plates or the two
sides of your living room.
So he thought it was
a pretty good idea.
He goes on ahead
in the mid 1890s.
He patents it, and
he promotes his ideas
through a series of lectures,
private demonstrations.
He invites people, good
friends like Mark Twain,
to come and play
with the apparatus.
And that, indeed,
is Twain, holding
about a hula-hoop-sized coil
over a Tesla transformer.
And there's a little light
bulb right about right
where his belly button is.
And the electricity that is
translated to the hula hoop
that you can see
causes that light bulb
to basically illuminate.
But he's got the right
idea in the wrong moment.
In the 1890s, there
is a major recession
following the panic of 1893.
Nobody is able to raise money
for any new high-tech ventures,
and nobody comes forward
to develop this idea.
Tesla experiments with a couple
of other ideas, with x-rays,
with radio-controlled
boats, but finally realizes
that he's got to
rethink wireless power.
OK, now, you've
all seen pictures
of radio waves or radio towers.
And they that at the
top of the radio tower
there's these concentric
spheres radiating out that
show you that the energy comes
off the top of a radio tower
and it goes in all directions.
And we really do mean
in all directions.
So it goes to the left.
It goes to the right.
It goes up.
It goes down.
It goes to Mars.
It goes to Jupiter.
It goes everywhere.
This annoyed the living
daylights out of Tesla.
He said, boys, girls, 99% of
the energy goes off into space.
And only maybe 1% ever
gets to your receiver.
This is a bad idea.
Tesla said, no, no, no, no.
What we're going to
do is we're going
to reconfigure our
transmitter circuits
so that we minimize the
amount of energy that goes up
to the antenna, and
we maximize the energy
that goes into the earth,
the ground current.
So what was Tesla thinking?
OK, on the top is how
Marconi, Lodge, everybody else
in electrical
engineering in the 1890s
thought about how radio worked.
So you got a transmitter.
You pump all the
energy up the antenna.
It goes across through the
ether, beep, beep, beep,
beep, from the transmitter's
antenna to the receiver
and is there converted into
music, into voice, whatever.
And both the receiver and
the transmitter are grounded,
so you have a complete
circuit that runs like this.
Thinking like a true maverick,
Tesla said, everybody's
got so hung up on the details.
This actually works
the other way.
As my English wife would
say, it's not clockwise.
It's anticlockwise.
What you want to do
with the transmitter
is you want to pump energy,
oscillating electric currents,
into the ground.
The energy goes
from the transmitter
through the ground,
beep, beep, beep,
beep, to the ground connection
underneath the receiver.
The receiver processes it,
either for voice or messages
or for power applications.
And you have some
sort of circuit
that is completed in
the high atmosphere,
as far as Tesla was concerned.
To prove this idea he goes
in 1899 to Colorado Springs.
And while he's there, he becomes
convinced that this whole thing
is actually going to work.
On the left-hand
side, you see there
his transmitter, which
consisted of a giant Tesla coil.
The primary, or the
coil, was basically
at the top of this
fence right here.
And it constituted a circle.
It was almost 50
feet in diameter.
The secondary of the
Tesla coil was over here,
and it basically
generated energy
that was pumped into the earth.
Now, because you
couldn't see anything
when the energy was
pumped into the earth,
they adjusted the coils
so that for the purposes
of these publicity photographs,
all the energy comes up,
goes to the ball.
And basically the
electrical voltages
are so high that
you ionize the air.
And you get these
sparks across the way,
and they're picked up by
a coil that you can't see.
It's just outside the
frame of this picture.
Now, Tesla thought that this
would give people a good idea
of how much power is involved.
By the way, Tesla tells
us in his notebooks
that this photograph here
is a trick photograph.
That is to say it was
made on a glass plate
and was done with two exposures.
The first exposure is, before
any of the electrical machinery
was turned on, Tesla sits there
and very calmly reads the book,
you know, probably
Maxwell's equations.
Then, he gets out of the chair.
And before they crank it up
and have hundreds of thousands
of volts going through the
air, he's out of the way.
So this is a trick
photograph, but the point
is he wanted to create the
illusion of the power that
was being moved or manipulated
at Colorado Springs.
Out in the pastures,
out in the fields right
next to Colorado Springs, this
was a typical sort of receiver.
This is a great
big coil, and you
can see that energy is
wireless, truly, transmitted.
And it makes this little light
bulbs light up down there.
Curious thing about
Colorado Springs
is every time Tesla
got evidence that
confirmed that energy
passed through the earth,
he was happy.
He never tried to torture
test his experiments
and disconfirm his hypothesis.
1900, Tesla returns to New York
City and announces to the world
that he is going
to transmit energy
and messages across the Atlantic
Ocean in eight months time.
He basically
publishes an article
in the equivalent of
today's "New Yorker,"
"The Century Magazine,"
that explains
that he has invented
everything you ever
need to know about
energy and how it's going
to change human civilization.
He lives the life of a winner.
He moves into the
Waldorf Astoria Hotel.
He wears the best clothes.
He strides down Fifth
Avenue like a peacock.
He eats dinner at
the best restaurants.
And to some extent, I would
say as a biographer, what's
going on in his mind
is the following.
If you say all the right things,
you do all the right things,
you're interviewed, you're
seen with all the right people,
then everything will
fall into place.
If you get the illusion
that you're a winner,
then you will be a winner.
The scheme works to
a certain extent.
In 1901 he secures
from JP Morgan,
the most powerful banker on
Wall Street, a loan of $150,000.
And to secure the loan,
Tesla offers and signs off
on giving Morgan 51%
of the patent rights.
Tesla fills in and
says, I'll give you 51%.
Morgan doesn't ask for this.
Tesla decides to give it to him.
Why?
In part, because he's
hoping that Morgan
will be the good
business partner
that Peck and Brown were
a decade or so earlier.
With that money, Tesla
builds, out on the North Shore
of Long Island, about 60
miles from New York City,
a new experimental
station at Wardencylffe.
This building is still standing.
This is the building
that if some of you
know that the oat meal
did a Kickstarter campaign
a few years back in 2012.
This is the building
that they rescued.
This is the tower.
And the important
thing is everybody
gets all worked up
about the power.
What's actually important is
there was a 120-foot-deep shaft
underneath the tower, which is
where Tesla anticipated he was
going to pump the energy in.
And as he said, Tesla
often said, in order
to get a grip on the
earth and shake it.
So what happens?
Everybody says that Tesla and
Edison had a terrible rivalry.
My friends, the rivalry
that really counted
was between Tesla and Marconi.
Tesla thought Marconi
was a Johnny-cone-lately,
good-for-nothing, low-life punk.
And those are just
the things I can
repeat in a public audience.
Marconi watches
Tesla like a hawk.
Marconi begins working on
basically his idea for wireless
telegraphy, sending
dots and dashes
using electromagnetic
waves, beginning in 1895.
Marconi does it by
first sending it a mile,
5 miles, 50 miles,
eventually, 100 miles.
By 1901, Marconi realizes
that if he's going to win,
he's going to have to
beat Tesla in getting
a message across
the Atlantic first.
And in December of 1901,
Marconi and his assistant
George Kemp are sitting,
freezing their butts off,
in Saint John's, Newfoundland.
And they hear,
faintly, the Morse code
signal for the letter S,
which Marconi had arranged
for his station on the
other side of the Atlantic,
in Cornwall, England, to
send at regular intervals.
December 12, they
hear the signal.
On December 14,
December 12's a Friday.
Sunday is, hence, the 14th.
Its front page new in
"The New York Times."
Pardon me, Marconi is regarded
as the new inventor of radio.
Tesla is a has-been.
Now, you took $150,000
from the most powerful man
on Wall Street.
You promised to be the
first to cross the Atlantic,
and this Italian
punk beats you to it.
What are you going
to say to JP Morgan?
How are you going
to deal with this?
Most of us would probably run
and hide behind the nearest
thing we could find.
Tesla had a unique mix
of bravado and courage
that fascinates me every
time I tell this story.
In February of 1902, Tesla says,
we're going to one up Marconi.
And he says, Mr.
Morgan, don't worry
about what Marconi is up to.
The major opportunity is
a world telegraphy system.
Imagine, if you will,
that outside every city
is a transmission plant
like Wardenclyffe.
And at those plants,
you send out,
by wire or by other means,
all the telegrams that you
need to send, all of the
stock quotations, all
of the telephone messages,
all of the fax messages
that you want to send, all of
the electronic information.
You tag it with
different frequencies,
and you pump it into the earth.
Everybody around the world
will have their own receiver
in their pocket, no bigger
than a pocket watch,
and they will be able to
receive the messages that
are relevant to them.
The whole Earth is like
a brain, as it were,
and the capacity of
this system is infinite.
You see, Mr. Morgan, the
revolutionary character
of this idea, it's
civilizing potency,
it's tremendous
money-making power.
Tesla had a vision in 1902
of an information revolution,
but not an
information revolution
that was business to business.
That's what everybody
else was talking about.
This was going to be an
information revolution
about individual
consumers, that everybody
would benefit by having access
to vast amounts of information.
Now, Tesla did not have
any idea about smartphones,
about the world wide web,
about search algorithms.
He didn't understand
that, but he had a vision
that the 20th century, and
indeed the 21st century,
was going to be about
information for everyone.
Consider this newspaper
story that comes from 1904.
There's his Wardenclyffe Tower.
Now, the author is
taking some liberties
in showing that radio
waves or signals are
going from the tower,
not through the earth,
but to individuals.
But look what's happening here.
You could be out
on a camping trip,
and you could take
your tent pole,
hold it up, and get information.
You could be out on your yacht.
This is a middle class or
upper middle class vision.
You'd be out on your
yacht, and you could
get signals via your mast.
Or my all time favorite
is the one in the middle.
You could be a lady on vacation
in the Berkshires, Saratoga,
and you want to know
the latest social news
from New York City or Boston.
You just hold up
your parasol, and you
can collect the information
on some sort of receiver
that you've got in your pocket
or your purse or somewhere
else.
Tesla saw a consumer revolution
in 1902 for information.
Now, Tesla fully understood that
you weren't going to make money
selling the information.
The information was
going to be for free.
You folks in this room know
all about dual-sided business
models.
You give away the
information for free,
and you collect the
money somewhere else.
Google does it
through advertising.
Morgan and Tesla thought
that they would do it
by basically selling
the receivers,
manufacturing and
selling the receivers.
Morgan, up to a point,
agreed with all of this.
And then something
happened on Wall Street.
A series of low
lives, particularly
Lee de Forest and Abraham
White, set up their own radio
companies.
And de Forest was the first
guy to use the word radio.
And they basically
created companies,
promised to build
technological systems,
and never delivered on
the systems that they had.
So, basically, it was
a stock market scam.
They'd sell the stock, and then
they'd run away with the money.
This created a crisis on
Wall Street, a small crisis.
And Morgan and other financiers
said, in Tesla's own words,
that they would not
touch wireless companies
with a 20-foot pole, that
they were just bad news.
And in 1903, Morgan
pulls out of the deal
that he has with Tesla.
Tesla continues to
look for other support,
but we have to go
back to that 51% deal.
Tesla basically had
given Morgan 51%.
Morgan said, if you get money
from anybody else, that's fine.
But I still get
51% of the revenue.
So other investors
who were looking
say, why are we going to put in
money if half the money or more
than half the money is
going to go to Morgan,
and he's a silent partner?
We're not interested.
Because he structured
the deal the wrong way,
Tesla was out of luck.
In the meantime, the press,
newspapers, technical journals,
had celebrated Tesla as the
second wizard, only second to
maybe Edison, or equal to
Edison, all through the 1890s,
all through the early 1900s.
Around 1904, 1905, the
press flips and decides
that he's a has-been.
He's a visionary and a poet.
In this time period--
1904, 1905-- Tesla
continues to fire off absolutely
crazy letters to Morgan.
Some of them are
just so sycophantic.
They just make your flesh crawl.
You go, oh, don't say that.
And then there's
others, like, I can't
believe you're not helping me.
You know, and
Morgan just decides,
I'm not going to
deal with this guy.
This guy is a nutcase.
At the same time,
Tesla's closest friend,
Richmond Hobson, that he's
really, really close to,
decides, yes, he's going to
marry a woman named Grizelda.
Sorry.
And Hobson wants to
run for Congress,
and so he needs to basically
be an upstanding, married guy.
And so Hobson
basically leaves Tesla.
And Tesla writes letters to
friends that basically indicate
that he's probably suffering
from mental depression
and nervous breakdown, and
he signs them Nikola Busted.
The last part of Tesla's
life is fairly sad.
He dies in 1943.
And he works on a couple
of things in the 1910s,
such as a bladeless
steam turbine
and some other minor inventions.
In the 1930s, he gets a
certain amount of publicity.
He announces that he's
developed a particle beam
weapon that can protect America
from long-range bombers.
And that results in,
shortly after his death,
that the FBI spends a brief
amount of time checking
his papers, decides that there
is, really, no particle beam
weapon.
But it sets up conspiracy
fans unto this day
that are convinced that there
was a particle beam weapon.
And in the 1950s, his papers
go to the people of Yugoslavia
as a gift from
the US government.
As I said in the
beginning, Tesla,
inventor, entrepreneur, artist.
He was an inventor.
One great success,
one great vision--
the alternating current
motor, wireless power--
in looking at these
things, whatever made him
a success also contributed
to his problems
with wireless power.
The mix of ideal and illusion--
he's an entrepreneur.
I want you to walk
away and sort of say,
this is a guy who
really understood
the strategy of patenting,
promoting, and selling.
And where do we see this?
We see this time and again when,
basically, people do IPOs out
in Silicon Valley.
They get good
intellectual property.
They promote it.
And they do the IPO,
and they sell it out.
He's an artist, not a scientist.
He's concerned
about the meaning.
What are people going to
think about my inventions?
How are they going to use it?
And his inventions came,
back to those dreams,
from an inner
ideal that he hoped
to impose on the world, a very
different sort of strategy
than most engineers or
other inventors use.
Tesla was a visionary leader.
We often say that necessity
is the mother of invention.
But I say to you,
breakthrough technologies
don't come with well-defined,
preexisting needs.
The connection
between the design
of the technology and this
ultimate social or economic use
is brokered, is
shaped, by inventors,
by the ability for
inventors or entrepreneurs
to tell powerful
stories that locate
that device with a
set of uses or wishes
that individual consumers have.
And that process is
often complicated.
And as Arthur C. Clarke said,
any sufficiently advanced
technology will appear as magic.
The connections that
individuals like Tesla make
are not always easy to discern.
Let me stop at this slide.
What's Tesla's legacy?
If you look at a
picture like this
that shows electric lights
on all over the world,
probably 99%, if not 99.99%,
of all the energy that's
used to power those electric
lights is done by alternating
current, is done by
using multi-phased power,
all of which Tesla invented.
I appreciate your time.
I suspect I've gone on
a little bit longer,
and I'd be happy to answer any
questions that you might have.
And thanks so much.
[APPLAUSE]
Questions?
AUDIENCE: So why aren't
we ever transmitting power
through the ground?
Was he just completely
wrong about the ground part,
or did we just get
distracted and, you know?
BERNARD CARLSON:
OK, so one version
would sort of say that we
didn't just get distracted,
but it wasn't a good
business proposition
for fat-cat capitalists,
like Morgan or Edison,
to basically get rid of
the copper-wire systems.
Now, I don't buy the business
explanation for this.
And to explain what
actually happened--
and there are still
people working on this.
There are people--
just bear with me here
as I find t he right slide.
Let's be clear that wireless
power works in certain ways.
So, for example,
through the 1990s,
the US Navy used extremely
low-frequency radio waves
that could travel
through what's called
the Schumann cavity,
which is the cavity that
is between the ionosphere and
deep into the Earth's crust.
And the waves would bounce
through that cavity,
and you could be
in radio contact
with nuclear subs that
were deep in the ocean.
And you could send
them a happy signal
so that they could be in touch.
And, indeed, where I lived
in Northern Michigan,
I taught for a few
years at Michigan Tech.
And about 100 miles to
the west of Michigan,
they built this huge,
110-mile antenna array
at Clam Lake, Wisconsin.
And it, indeed, was
the way that the navy
kept in touch with the subs.
So you can send radio
waves, you can send energy,
through the earth, and
that's what this illustrates.
A company that's
actually got roots here
in Cambridge and at MIT
actually uses a wireless system,
at least over short
range, to, as you can see,
charge up cell phones that
are parked on a little tray.
And there's a coil, which is
the transmitter, in the tray,
and then there's a coil
that's in a substitute
back on the phone that
allows you to charge it up.
The vision is that
you'll be able to walk
into your office or
your home at some point,
and you won't even have to take
the phone out of your pocket
or out of your purse.
The phone will just
sense that it's
in an electromagnetic field,
and it will charge itself.
So over short distances,
there's probably wireless power
applications that we'll see used
more widely in our lifetime.
Now, could you do this
all over the world?
All right, now, the
answer, I think, is no.
But remember, I'm a historian.
I'm not an engineering guy.
The problem is, as I say, is
the Earth like a water balloon
or like an ocean?
Tesla thought that the Earth
was like a water balloon, which
it was filled with an
incompressible fluid.
And if you pumped, like he
shows on the left-hand side,
at a certain frequency, i.e. the
resonant frequency of the Earth
or the water
balloon, eventually,
you'd reach the point where
with each subsequent stroke
of the little pump, you'd
have water popping out
of these one-way valves.
Now, we're using a
hydraulic analogy here.
Tesla, of course, is
talking about doing this
with electrical energy.
The problem is, how
does the Earth respond
to that electrical energy?
Is the Earth like an
incompressible fluid,
or is it like a
compressible fluid?
In other words, is
the situation such
that if you threw a
rock into the ocean,
the waves don't
travel from where
I grew up in New Jersey
all the way to Spain?
Eventually, through
friction in the fluid, i.e.
the ocean, the waves peter out.
And that's how the
Earth actually responds
to electromagnetic waves.
OK, so that's my understanding.
Now, you've hopped up in the
middle of this, my good sir.
You've got a great
question for me.
AUDIENCE: OK, so
you've studied Tesla.
You must have come across
this article, well, interview
transcription, from
1899 with John Smith.
BERNARD CARLSON: Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK, so it sounds
to me like he really
conflates electromagnetism
and spirituality to an excess.
He sounds like a nut case to me.
What would be your
assessment of that?
BERNARD CARLSON: OK, so the
musical composer, Phil Klein,
within the last, like,
two or three weeks,
sent me this article.
So I've only skimmed it, and
I am trying to figure it out.
But my gut reaction is
this article is a hoax.
I don't think it's the real deal
because I've spent 15 years,
and I'm pretty sure I've seen
most of the critical stuff
on Tesla.
And there is no provenance
associated with this article.
It's not like, oh, it came
from "The New York Times"
and it was published on
such and such a date.
But I have to say,
I haven't actually
done all, as the lawyers would
say, the due diligence on this.
Now, there is a certain amount
of interesting interweaving
of different things if you go
back to that "Century" article
that Tesla published in
1900 about the future
of electrical energy
and human civilization.
And when I actually do this,
sort of the Smith article,
if you will, the
Smith interview is
as I'm going to be looking
at it in parallel with what
Tesla says and how Tesla
says things in the "Century"
article.
So I'm not convinced.
Tesla had a big vision,
but I'm not sure
that I'm convinced
that the Smith
interview is the real deal.
Sir, I got you warmed up.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thanks, so
Tesla must have been aware
of the inverse square law
because Maxwell's equations had
already been published.
But you were also
noting how he was more
of an artist than a tinkerer.
So when thinking
about things like,
I'm going to transmit
to the entire Earth,
was he thinking about that?
Or did he just think
he could, you know,
think his way beyond it?
BERNARD CARLSON: OK,
an absolutely spot on
question-- he didn't believe
that the inverse square law
applied to the
propagation of the waves
that he was generating.
Now, his big idea
was he was going
to set up in the Earth,
if you're at Colorado
Springs, stationary waves.
In other words, you'd hit
the resonant frequency
of the Earth.
And this room is perfect.
You know, I can see it.
I apologize if you have
to turn around and back.
But he imagined that there would
be a wave travelling through
the Earth, much like the way
the lighting is on that wall.
If, he figured, I set
up this stationary wave,
there are minimal energy
losses as the energy moves
through the crust of the Earth.
So he thought that
the inverse square law
didn't apply in his situation.
Obviously, it does, and that
was one of the problems.
Tesla was an individual
who actually worked out
all of this stuff.
He thought that what
he was observing
in electromagnetic waves was
not transverse waves, again,
like you see, or
which is approximated
by the lights on the wall.
But he actually
thought that you had
the waves that were
longitudinal waves like you
have in a slinky.
In other words, they're
like sound waves.
And Tesla was so sure of this
that he actually went to Hertz
and visited him and hold
Hertz that Hertz was wrong.
Now, where this gets really
deep and complicated,
and I'm about to, you know,
basically put on my water wings
to say this.
If you get into a big
discussion with people
about electromagnetic
propagation,
they will tell you that
Maxwell's equations--
some will tell you that
Maxwell's equations predict
that there are two parts
to the propagation.
There is the
transverse wave, which
is what we think about
most of the time,
but there is also a scalar
wave that goes with it.
And depending on
who you talk to,
some people would say
that Tesla had it right,
that more of the electromagnetic
propagation phenomenon
is about scalar waves and
not electromagnetic waves.
Sadly, these people
then immediately go off
onto this sort of
conspiracy thing
which is, once again, that RCA
and Marconi and other people
had basically suppressed the
truth about scalar waves.
Now, every time I
want to know-- I'm
a professor in an
engineering school.
Every time I want to know
about scalar, the scalar
dimension of
electromagnetic propagation,
I go see my friends in
the electrical engineering
department.
They kind of look at me
like, I don't know, dude.
We're talking, like, serious
electrical engineering
theology.
I don't know whether we're
going to actually talk
to you about this.
There may be something
to this, but it
is beyond the scope
of what I understand.
But you hit it spot on, and
I appreciate you bringing up
the inverse square law.
Tesla did not believe
the inverse square law
applied to him.
Great, all righty, let me
turn around and say to you,
I think this is a guy that
talks about the information
revolution.
This is somebody who's
talking about the information
revolution in ways that Google
is acting on, day in, day out,
this notion that
information should
be broadly available to
lots and lots of people.
And how are you
going to deliver it
in ways that are
good for the people
but also profitable
for the company?
I mean, does this
resonate with you folks,
or am I saying something
that's like, dude, it's
like the water we swim in,
nothing really to say about it?
But I kind of want to stick
him in there, you know,
that he's about a
different sort of story
about how electrical and
electronic technologies are
going to change our lives.
He's not an Edison character.
And there's reasons
why he's often
thrown into contrast
with Edison because Tesla
had a very different
social vision than Edison.
But you all have
day jobs to go to.
I'm doing my day
job, as a teacher,
so thank you very much.
Thanks for coming out.
I'm happy to sign some books.
[APPLAUSE]